what does Top Gun have in common with
films like The Bling Ring and Hustlers
you ask well all of these films were
inspired by magazine articles the
magazine article in question was titled
Top Guns and it was published by
California magazine in 1983. the piece
covers the high octane world of fighter
pilots one element of the film that was
clearly inspired by the article is the
nicknames of the pilots the article
explained that Pilots were often called
things like Yogi Gringo Gator and possum
while there's not a specific pilot
mentioned in the article that directly
inspired Maverick the article goes into
the intensity of the job and how many
Pilots lived for the Glorious and
terrifying thrill of flying Tomcats
these days because Top Gun has made the
real school so famous students at the
Navy fighter weapon School are actually
fined five dollars every time they
reference the film while at the Academy
I feel the need get out
get out